your husband wyatt is the son of goldie
hawn
um and kurt russell i remember whenever
i was i
actually was friends with reba before
but i ended up
being related to her because of it but
it was so funny it was interesting
because i was friends first but isn't
that weird to like grow up with someone
that you've seen and then all of a
sudden you're like
they're your in-laws isn't that weird
yeah it is kind of weird i think
the reason you know it's funny because i
just loved him so much that there was
something in my brain that was like i
just want my in-laws to like me and then
i would occasionally remember
like oh that's that's this person who
i've seen here but they're just the most
normal i mean people say that about you
know but
it's just like you kind of forget pretty
quickly absolutely
sometimes it hits me they're the best
they really are no it is always funny
though i was i was lucky i felt like
that would have been
when i found this out about you i was
like oh if i would if that would have
happened
opposite like i was friends with reba
first and then that happened without
an opposite i'd have been terrified i
would have not wanted to say the wrong
thing ever
i would have been like just scared but
um no i don't yeah
they are so welcoming that i was i
definitely came into it i think
i think the first time my parents met
them i'm from the south i'm from texas
too so i'm from texas
my mom my mom had like a rhinestone
shirt that said hollywood on it or
she'll kill me
i can't remember saying this oh no but
um
i was i was like i was nervous at first
and then it went away within five
seconds and now we've been together five
and a half years and
they're just like crazy yeah no it wears
all yeah definitely not wears off it
just
wears it it becomes normal subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going